I'm often criticized for a lot of things
but I'm often criticized for saying I'm
out of touch you don't know what you're
talking about because you haven't been
there and done that
now I stay in really close touch so I
really actually do know exactly what is
going on in the world of money and in
the world of your finances what I am in
touch with is the fact that I'm old
which means I've seen more than some of
you have seen been there done that
so an example of that is but when I tell
people in Anthony O'Neill rmz
personality tells people in his new book
debt-free degree that you can go to
college and work your way through oh no
Dave that only happened back when you
roamed the earth with the dinosaurs in
today's world with colleges expensive as
it is that is impossible says people who
can't run a calculator so no you cannot
go to college and work ten hours a week
at Burger King being a whopper flopper
at minimum wage you cannot do that by
the way in 1982 when I graduate from
college you couldn't do it then either
minimum wage has never been enough to
get you through college so I don't know
which one of you socialist idiots
figured out a way that minimum wage was
somehow supposed to pay you enough to go
through college no you have to work at
something that pays more than minimum
wage and you have to work more than ten
hours a week and then you can pay for
college for instance it is very normal
around here when I ask someone doing
their debt free scream what their side
gig was they say delivering pizza and I
say how much did you make $1,500 a month
working four to five nights a week
which by the way in case you don't know
what nights means it means all your days
are open to go to class your nights are
not open to play Pierre to play beer
pong
or to get rushed in the fraternity oh
wow we're talking about getting an
education here getting a degree and
learning something this is the goal so
if you actually cut grass walks dogs are
you were a nanny
the average is 20 to 12 clean houses
that's a good one
get on your hands and needs to scrub a
freaking toilet out 25 bucks an hour on
average 20 bucks an hour on average 40
hours a week 30 hours a week while you
go to school I worked 40 to 60 hours a
week when I was in school and you can
pay for the average tuition in America
for an in-state college which is twelve
thousand dollars a year now that does
not include living in the dorms and the
Atlantic is publishing an article being
a college student is a lot comfier than
it used to be this fall many of the
undergrads settling into their campus
dwellings will find themselves in
buildings far better appointed than the
ones there now graying that would be me
alumni once called home you know the
dorms that were there when I went to
college looked very similar to prisons
it was a concrete block freakin wall
with a metal thing attached to it that
you put a bad mattress on and called it
a room oh and by the way you shared it
with other individuals as opposed to a
bunch of you who have grown up never
having shared a room with anyone because
well we couldn't have that it would be a
dysfunctional family where we'd all to
share rooms
most of us in another generation grew up
sharing rooms we learn to have these
things called relationships and our
family as a result sometimes the
relationships are good sometimes they
were bad but we had relationships
because we were sharing things now most
people don't know the name of their
next-door neighbor and they for sure
don't know the person on the other side
of their next-door neighbor and they
take that off to college with them
because their kids were trained that way
and they don't know how to have
relationships down the hallway unless
it's over Instagram they don't know how
to sit and talk to another human being
eyeball to eyeball kneecap to kneecap
and so we have to have our own private
rooms
in the dorms these students are the
beneficiaries of a generation of
construction that has spawned ritzy new
dorms and other facilities the article
says it at many colleges as well as more
infamously such amenities as rock
climbing walls and lazy rivers in the
dorms you're getting me so college costs
a lot more than it used to cost hmm you
used to stay in a concrete block wall
room with another student that cost a
few dollars to put up per student now
you're staying there with multiple
devices on Wi-Fi we want to make the
Architectural Digest
with our dorm room building says one
college and campus living has entered a
new era for most of the history of
American higher education dormitories
we're not particularly comfortable or
even plentiful and yet we say you cannot
afford to go to college today and Dave
you can't work your way through well
would it be reasonable for me to submit
to you that part of the cost of
increased cost of your college going
through the roof would be the fact that
the quality and the amenities of your
housing for students has gone crazy thus
the cost went crazy would that be too
illogical for some of you to grasp so
you're paying for this crap in other
words now in my case I lived off campus
in a we called it the cabin it was a
shanty that had no heat that my
grandfather built on the side of the
river and I got to live there I thought
it was cool because on the river and I
liked the water ski but you know it was
pretty cool until we figured out it
didn't have stinking heat we had to get
up and light a fire in the morning to
get warm in the winter
next winter we put in a heater by God
that was ridiculous but yeah Wes Frost
stayed and one winter I didn't have the
money to go back to college and I ended
up cutting firewood do you know if you
cut enough firewood and sell it to
people who want like a quart of wood a
Rick of wood
with a chainsaw and a splitter that you
can go back to school as long as the
school's not trying to finance in your
tuition a lazy river ride see the
problem you know I don't know where
people think that you know you got your
own little ritz-carlton going here for
your little baby snowflake and then you
wonder why these stinking tuition rates
have gone through the roof while housing
costs for college has gone through the
roof it's not simply that they're
providing the same exact thing they used
to provide they're providing 10x of what
they used to provide they're charging
12x of what they used to provide and oh
yeah you can afford to go to school
still if you go to an end state school
Community College and you work a job
that actually pays and you work it a lot
check out Anthony's new book debt-free
degree it'll show you every bit of that
but it won't hook you up or the dorm
with a lazy river ride lord help us